bonjour merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation alors en une semaine quatre
candidats à l'élection présidentielle
nicaraguayennes ont été arrêtées dans ce
petit pays d'amérique centrale
quelles sont les raisons invoquées par
les autorités comment peut-on qualifier
ce genre de manoeuvre oui bonjour merci
de m'avoir invité du nicaragua petit
pays très emblématique de cette amérique
latine avec centrale qui tourne en rond
qui se targue dans un débat qui
ressemble aux années 50 60 la
souveraineté l'impérialisme américain
bon monsieur ortega est issu et ria
communiste qui a vaincu qui a vaincu
notamment les etats-unis se rappelle
années 80 de regan qui est intervenu en
au nicaragua et le régime maintenant il
s'est momifié il est en train de se
décrotter c'est devenu une affaire de
famille monsieur ortega neuf enfants je
crois naturels ou adoptifs je sais plus
huit sont des conseillers du
gouvernement les y sont installés dans
les grandes entreprises
là où les marges les plus élevées donc
ça devient assez comique
on se croirait dans l'egypte de moubarak
avant en 2011 et là ils le régime a
inventé des lois pour empêcher de la
vérité pour empêcher l'exercice de la
démocratie
vannes - notamment guillotine que vous
avez cités qui le 2020
et qui dit que toute toute critique du
gouvernement peut être prises considéré
comme du terrorisme ou natal la sécurité
d'état bon ça rappelle pas cessé on ne
peut pas ne pas condamner gi derrière
j'espère qu'on pourra en parler il y a
une vraie bataille entre les etats-unis
et les pays de son arrière cour en
amérique latine alors justement les
états unis ont infligé des sanctions
financières à 4 proche du président
nicaraguayen de sa propre fille vous
pensez que ces sanctions américaines
sont
suffisante efficace selon vous pour
tenter d'empêcher d'enrayer la situation
pour les sanctions il ya deux écoles
il ya ceux qui sont qui ce que ça ne
marche jamais dos qui disent que ça le
ca peut éventuellement fonctionner moi
je pense que ne pas pouvoir faire du
business aux états unis contourner
latino américains c'est très dur ça va
avoir un impact même si le l'entourage
de monsieur ortega n'est pas n'est pas
sont pas des amateurs sont certainement
des crypto monnaie ils ont certainement
d'autres moyens de profiter de leur
fortune est de faire de l'argent mais
c'est vrai que les sanctions font mal
mais ce que joue le régime c'est autre
chose qu'un voyage à miami ou l'achat
d'une maison à hambach il joue sa vie il
joue sa vie parce que là ils ont
tellement pris de place dans l'économie
ils ont tellement colonisé le pays d'un
point de vue économique parasitaire que
s'il ya une révolution ils vont ils
risquent gros et laisseront leur vie
donc là le la limite les sanctions
pourquoi pas ça peut ça fait plaisir à
tout le monde les américains m en dos et
la veste de la défense de la démocratie
entre guillemets même si je ne suis pas
anti américain j'aimerais bien les
américains tiennent le même discours dur
elle traite de dictateur voire ahmed ben
salman en arabie saoudite parce que
sincèrement c'est ces deux poids deux
mesures
mais je ne veux pas polémiquer alors le
gouvernement nicaraguayen qualifie ces
sanctions américaines de mesures je cite
illégale et arbitraire qui confirme que
les opposants souhaitent vendre la
patrie à l'étranger vous en pensez quoi
bon chacun dans son rôle
les opposants votre sympathie puisqu'ils
sont minorités et piles risques et sont
prises on l'a donc nous as raison lance
rentre sympathie n'oublions pas que du
fond de la politique ce ne sont pas des
saints pour tout le monde et s'ils
jouent un jeu les américains ou fait ils
ont pris là le drapeau de la liberté des
droits de l'homme
c'est bien mais il faut pas mais quel
est leur but leur but c'est d'avoir
accès à des écosystèmes ouvert ce qu'est
l'intérêt des américains avec du sud
ce n'est pas le bien-être des peuples
d'amérique du sud il ce n'est pas le
bien-être ou le bonheur du peuple
nicaraguayen ce qui est important pour
eux c'est d'avoir un éco système
politique ouvert où les capitaux
circulent vous avez vu la loire ils
veulent que l'ue ait said i d'ailleurs
c'est un problème au nicaragua elle
donne de l'argent à des fondations des
droits de l'homme
ils veulent que nos ong de new york ou
los angeles donne de l'argent à une ong
clé car en moyenne des droits de la
femme
ils veulent qu'il y ait un pluralisme
même factice straw avec un vol s'est
organisé le tournoi comme une coupe du
monde peu importe qu'on élise la droite
la gauche
ils vivent très bien avec la gauche
brésilienne qui pourtant anticapitaliste
et ils vivent très bien avec l'extrême
droite colombienne qui est dur parfois
donc le problème pour les américains
c'est pas vraiment le contenu de cette
démocratie où le fait que le lundi de
développement humain au nicaragua
s'améliore au brésil en colombie
ce qui compte c'est qu'ils puissent
accéder aux acteurs leur faire pression
par ses c'est l'histoire de sanctions
ces histoires d'accès au système swift
ces histoires de voyages aux états unis
parce que pour nous on avait mieux de
ses importants les états unis célébrant
ses grands voisins
voyez c'est donc d'elle tout ça s'est
travesti d'ailleurs une rhétorique est
gentil qu'on aime bien les droits de
normes le pauvre peuple nicaraguayen
mais bon quand je vous ai dit c'est
vraiment à la députée en dhr escaliers
merci d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes spécialiste en
relations internationales
merci beaucoup